this is the only health facility at
village 8 refugee camp near sudan's
border with ethiopia
dozens come here for medical assistance
each day teclo will die says he was worn
by doctors back in his home country
ethiopia
that he was developing cardiac problems
now he says days of walking to flee from
fighting in ethiopia's tigre region
and standing in line for aid and for
treatment is making him feel worse
i was told to be careful not to exhaust
myself to take care of my diet
but since i had to flee my chest pains
have been increasing
and when i come here there's often a
long line or no doctor
for hundreds of patients in the camp
that hosts more than fifteen thousand
the center is the first and sometimes
the only place to seek treatment
despite that it has little to offer to
patients all who fled to escape fighting
from tigray
i wasn't suffering from anything when i
was back at my cadre
i've been struggling to get medication
since i got here and the treatment is
very poor
more than 45 000 refugees have been
displaced by the fighting integrity
it started three weeks ago following a
government offensive on the tigari
people's liberation front
the offensive was a response to an
attack by the front on a military base
and came after months of tension between
the regional government and the federal
government
two camps have been opened in sudan to
cope with the influx of refugees
but providing services especially health
services
is challenging as more and more refugees
continue to arrive
the camp here has three doctors who are
also refugees to tend to the sick
we don't have even a single microscope
we cannot do blood filling for malaria
we don't have
at least you know basic steroid tests
that could be of some benefit there are
many
cases with chronic diseases like
diabetes and
cardiac cardiac diseases but we don't
have the drugs
we don't have a single supply of a
single item of anti-diabetic drug for
instance
sudan's commission of refugees says it's
trying to assist the refugees with
access to health care
but needs support from organizations to
be able to help the sick
what's needed is for health
organizations to provide emergency
medications
the refugee community is now mingling
with the local community
and some turn to local health facilities
to get treatment
health organizations need to step up to
ensure that refugees have proper health
care
most refugees here say they don't know
how long they remain in this camp
or if they will be relocated to places
with better facilities
but they say they hope their calls for
assistance will be listened to
before a medical crisis occurs hebrew
morgan al-jazeera al-fashed
god of state